[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys it's the summer season the Sun
is out and I'm sure you'll be heading to
the beach I know I am and the breeze is
just so cooling so today's workout will
be working on your arms and also your
apps we want to tone up on these two
areas no equipment needed all you need
is your own body weight and it's only a
15 minutes workout so get this workout
done at your home or by the beach let's
do it
each workout will be for 40 seconds long
and you will get a 20 seconds break so
this workout is suitable for everybody
okay
so the first workout is going to be
Barry Jack's get into a high plank
position all right I want you to check
out when you check in get into a knee
tucks okay so out in bring your knees in
out in good bring it low almost touching
the ground very good low but do not
touch so that workout will really engage
your core movement good check out in
hole in socket tummy is like a core in
as you bring your knees down and bending
it good keep going out in bed it then
very good so almost touching keeping
your arm strong we are also working on
your arm muscles okay very good keep
going out in last few more that's one
more give me one more and rest it out
second workout will be a push up to
downward dog so we want to work on one
leg frist let's bring our left leg up
okay so ten more seconds rest I want you
to give me a nice push up and to
downward dog
alright simple but very effective hold
the body movement let's go push up and
Pike up very good push up nice pike up
stretch your back feel your back muscles
and up for your core working
your upper body as well beginners if
you're struggling then what you can do
is just get into a high plank and
straight into downward dog very good
high plank
downward dog as you progress get into a
loop push up and bring your leg squeeze
your butt
good so maintaining this position will
work on your corn very good next we want
to work on the other side all right
so breathe in feel the breeze get ready
the other side five more seconds rest
all right so push up to downward dog on
the opposite leg ah I'm feeling the
workout already let's go up push up
squeeze the opposite leg down up and
squeeze stretch bring your butt as high
as you can reach up for your arms
reaching your shoulders your triceps and
also your car down and squeeze the butt
good it's a total body workout at the
same time feel your car tuck your tummy
in again beginners remember you can
always start from a high plank and
squeeze up good everybody needs a
starting point and this is a really good
workout up and press it out whoa breathe
in breathe out
now get down sit on your mat I want to
get into a knee tucks okay so a v-tach
that's it small but very effective
workout on your upper and your lower ass
breathe in let's go support yourself up
knee tucks up and it talks good so small
movement was really effective on the
core good keep going support yourself
relax your shoulders focus on your abs
your core good up
and tuck it in very good kid going coop
breathe in and breathe out
ha it is so warm right now 10 more
seconds
keep going up and down good plug it in
bring it up just small lift up last one
and rest it out right cross chamber
let's get back into a high plank instead
of the regular mountain climber I want
you to cross your left knee to your
right elbow to cross and cross okay whoa
three more seconds rest let's get ready
I play and let's go cross and cross good
all right it's not about rushing to work
out but rather it's about reaching your
knee to your elbow engaging and twisting
and feeling your obliques good keep
crossing and twist and feel your
obliques okay maintain a high plank
position
do not hike your butt up good twist and
look the opposite direction very good
keep going you should feel your heart
rate pumping suck the core in okay one
last one and rest right let's work more
on our side obliques okay so get into a
plank position
on your elbows I want you to come up
okay hands up as you rotate reach and
okay that's it so it's about lifting the
side of your abs ready let's go twist
reach and up look up good control and
control it's not always about moving and
jumping constantly sometimes when you
control the movement when you control
and hold the pose
it makes the workout even harder keep
going twist remember lift your obliques
up okay don't drop it don't drop your
hips do not drop your butt look up to
the beautiful sky
very good twist and look up keep going
twist and up twist and up strong
shoulders strong arms and rest it out
right opposite side very good
right um hang on with me okay you have a
couple more workouts let's get up into a
play hold this plank position okay so
reach up it's all about lifting this pot
right here okay lift this part up down
twist and reach good twist look over and
reach good stack your legs together
again if you're struggling you can
always stop on your knees keep going
keep twisting down it up very good keep
going you're not stopping right now see
your sweat dripping feel your heart rate
and keep pushing it very good whew reach
up look up give thanks to a beautiful
day up keep reaching last one and rest
it up one more last one gone my hair is
absolutely messy right now okay final
workout I want you to get into a lateral
walk so we got to start from the end of
the mat okay give me one spider-man okay
and let's walk ready let's go let's walk
to the end one spider-man 2 spider-man
and let's walk back now give me three
crunch again working on the slide of
your obliques
very good now walk back control okay
keep your hips low keep your plank
strong gives me four to three my sweat
is absolutely dripping for one last walk
walk back and last one oh you can one
and rest it out
I'm absolutely drenched in sweat I told
you I'm going to get you bikini body all
ready okay so breathe take a shot one
mini break keep yourself hydrated and we
want to do
second set breathe in and out don't run
away okay see you soon
[Music]
another 15 seconds left take this time
to really hydrate yourself and you know
all the work out so I want you to give
me your best effort okay
let's start with pair jacks five seconds
left start in a high plank position
Jack out and in okay out in Beninese
squeeze the core bring your knees
together bring your knees down almost
touching the mat pull it and back out
good
out and in keep your knees soft and your
arms and shoulders strong very good out
and in
keep going and just gently relax your
neck okay
gaze gently at your mat keep going
you're very strong good give me few more
look out and in add it in suck your
belly in okay every time you engage your
core that's when you work more on your
car all right relax second work out push
up to downward dog all right let's start
on our left leg remember if you can't do
push-up you can always start on your
knees and then eventually progress okay
or start in a high plank position three
more seconds breathe in and up let's go
push-up up and squeeze straighten
point your toes squeeze stretch up back
down and stretch your triceps your arms
look in between your legs very good keep
going push up and look in between good
this is an advanced move again beginner
you can always start in a high plank
position push back squeeze the glutes
through your left glute working and up
good keep going down it up easy
breathing
good I'll squeeze and press it out take
this moment to really breathe to really
catch your breath
slow your breathing down okay the better
your pace your breathing and the longer
you
we'll be able to sustain your workout
all right five more seconds high plank
again ready right leg up and that's
gonna push up and squeeze up good down
and up
squeeze good spread the palms wide up to
find your balance okay pointer toes keep
them strong and engage your leg muscles
as well squeeze down and up good and up
this is also a yoga move down and up and
squeeze through your shoulders working
and gauging together breathe guys hang
in there and rest
take a deep breathing now let's go on to
your butt we want to work on knee tucks
with a lift
okay so talk to a V ready relax the
shoulders just place your palms on the
floor and just relax your upper body I
really work on the upper and lower abs
tuck and small lift good tuck and small
leave even if you can't lift your leg
high just a small lift we'll get you
started okay so up tuck it in knees in
up and tuck it in up again
pumps spread them wide relax your upper
body it's just to support you up and
tuck it in up and very good guys every
time you feel your muscles working
that's when you're pushing your limits
and that's when you will see growth and
changes very good okay you don't stop
when you're tired you stop when you are
done and wrap next let's get back into a
high plank position okay cross climber
remember it's not about rushing the
workout it's about engaging every single
core muscles and I'll see your good
muscles okay so up high plank three
seconds ready let's go cross it and
cross okay drive your knee to the
opposite elbow good cross and cross good
view your obliques working very good
okay we like to show this and you will
also strengthen your wrists
keep going twist and twist see your
sweat dripping okay see it drip let it
drip
feel your heart rate feel all the hard
work yes puddin you're not far off from
being done okay only three more sets
very good keep going last few more two
seconds left and rest it out
whew side plank okay side plank twists
right let's get onto your left side
start on a low plank beginners you can
always start on your knees okay this is
a beginner movement twist and reach as
you progress then get into a full plank
on your side let's go up reach in twist
up good balance
use your core your slight obliques to
find your balance twist look the
opposite side it's magic second twist
and rotate very good rotate all the way
you look up lift your hips off the mat
keep going
breathe in and breathe out you have 10
seconds left
breathe in and breathe out
hey sir breathing find your rhythm okay
in your workout the moment you find your
rhythm the more you will enjoy your
workout so let's go on the other side
this entire mat is literally filled with
my sweat right now okay
so wipe it off let's not stop right now
right side straighten both legs
okay engage the side of your core let's
bring yourself up straight up and let's
go twist and up good rotate all the way
Felix rotate very good strengthen those
shoulder muscles on your right side
good keep doing this okay minimal
movement but really effective workout
whoa I promise you you would get a break
after this and another workout okay good
jump into the beach swim in the ocean if
you want to or the beautiful pool right
behind me very good keep going
rich twist reach one more twist and
reach one final workout okay let's rock
the plank walk to spider-man so again
start right at the end of your mat give
me one spider-man and we will build from
there all right I'm gonna take this time
to breathe first right let's go
spider-man one walk type in a core keep
your back flat strong abs to spider-man
to walk back okay no piking this is
wrong okay keep your body flat and low
three one more elbow to knee walk back
strong arms okay
strengthen the arm muscles and work on
those flabby arm muscles good keep going
give me four on this side let's walk
back
flat back suck your belly in give me
five okay one two last one three we're
not stopping right now for last one
rested you should be looking like this
at the end of your workout a kid
drenched in sweat but I'm feeling so
good I want you to do this workout
consistently for at least three to four
times weekly okay and I promise you you
will start to see results on your body
your arms your core muscles and even
your legs will start to tone up alright
catch your breath
keep yourself hydrated jump into the
pool go to the beach whatever you want
remember to keep your work a consistent
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up like this video share this video and
hit the subscribe button if you haven't
yet done it because I get promise you
every week you will be sweating and you
will be a better version of yourself all
the best